you can still have biological children  with a trans partner in the same way  that like two lesbians can have a  biological child two gay men can have a  biological child two men cannot have a  biological child together neither can  two women and i want you to really think  about the fact that i need to explain  this i need to explain it actually needs  to be explained that two men can't make  a baby you are really dumb for real if i  had a 100 billion dollars to start my  own social media site  um i tell you what i would do  i would de-platform people and ban them  purely on the basis of being stupid that  that's the kind of d platforming that i  would like to see if you are that level  of stupid you don't get to be on any  platform  that's it  you shouldn't have access to an audience  you shouldn't be speaking to thousands  or millions of people if you're the  one of the dumbest people on planet  earth come on man if i had the ability  that's how i would de-platform people